let's talk stock market and personal
finance a little bit many of you know i
love talking about this stuff it's
actually uh you know my my formal
training is not actually in politics
it's in economics and finance and i love
talking about this stuff and as always
i don't give financial advice on this
show but i have shared my approach which
is
if the stock market goes up
i keep buying my mutual funds if the
stock market goes down i keep buying my
mutual funds with the idea that i'm
getting a discount and eventually
they'll go up because over the long term
the stock market returns you know
roughly seven percent per year or
whatever the case may be we are now
starting to see more and more of these
sort of like fear articles one example
is from um
thursday
when it was looking we were in the
middle of like the fourth straight
decline in the stock market
and or a slight decline and the article
says
stocks were little changed thursday with
wall street hoping to stave off a fourth
consecutive day of losses as investors
struggle to reconcile a still-hot jobs
market with the economy that's had its
momentum dented by soaring covet
infections on wednesday the dao and s p
500 had their third day in a row of
losses
the tech laced nasdaq fell for the first
time since last week the markets taking
disappointing news and stride as i've
said so many times before
this is the type of stuff that i don't
think makes sense to pay attention to
what do we know
overall
there are market corrections and over
the long term the market goes up
timing the market is not advantageous if
you
have a certain amount of money each
month that's available for investment
you don't say or i don't say
the historical evidence suggests it's
not a good idea to say
well i think it's a little high let me
hold this month's money till next month
and then when the market goes down i'll
invest two months that is not
historically advantageous and so for me
this is mostly noise and very little
signal
and i'm going to give you in a moment my
sense of what is likely to happen with
the disclaimer that i have no idea
obviously before i do that i want to
mention that this segment like some of
our other financial segments
is sponsored by policy genius if someone
relies on your financial support whether
it's a child aging parent business
partner life insurance is something that
can be affordable and that it makes
sense to look into but you've got to
find the right policy for you that's a
tricky thing
people often don't really know what
should i be paying for life insurance
what kind of life insurance do i need i
used to work in this field
when i was in college i interned with a
life insurance company and these are the
complicated questions that policy genius
solves policy genius makes it easy to
compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place
you could save thirteen hundred dollars
or more per year on life insurance by
using policy genius to compare policies
go to policygenius.com david pakman show
spend a few minutes you'll work out how
much coverage do you need you'll get a
personalized quote the policy genius
team will handle all of the paperwork
with no extra fees and without selling
your information this will give you a
sense of relief to get it out of the way
and go over to
policygenius.com
david pakman show to get started now
i believe that there is a case to be
made
that we are heading for a significant
market correction oh oh my goodness
david david why how how are you when
i have no idea
what i mean is
uh over the last
many years when i look at my investment
account my mutual fund stocks and bonds
um
it says 17 annualized return over the
last significant period of time
that's not normal okay because the
market historically returns somewhere
around seven percent a year depending on
whether you're doing inflation
adjustment or not and okay it's just a
rough number
so
if things are going to continue being
the way they've been in the past of
which there's no guarantee but there's a
pattern that markets tend to follow
at some point the huge growth we've seen
for years
is going to be corrected
and so my expectation is
without any particular prediction and
without saying you need to do anything
as a result which i would never tell you
is that we're going to see a correction
at some point now it could be in six
months
it could be in a year could be in two
years it could be in five years i have
no idea
my strategy doesn't change which is i'm
in it for the long haul i want a dollar
cost average in i don't want to try to
time the market when we had the crash at
the start of the pandemic
and maybe that was going to go on six
months 12 18 who knew
i just kept buying
and it very quickly recovered
that may happen again it may not we just
don't know and so the point here is
looking only historically
the returns over the last period of time
are high
and that signals to me that at some
point they will come back down because
of a correction what will i do at that
time i will just keep buying i will see
it as a discount on assets that
eventually go up and an opportunity to
get more shares because remember a
hundred bucks when when prices are lower
a hundred bucks gets you more shares and
therefore more dividends that's my
approach there's no magic to it there's
no timing there's no research there's
nothing it's just i'm going to keep
dollar cost averaging in let me know
your thoughts